yeah that's it that's a good question I
you know
I picked the issue of hunger because it
seemed to drop in my lap and it could
have been because of the Peace Corps but
I think it was because of this 1984
experience I had in Ethiopia and why
would I be involved with hunger because
I've never been hungry in my life except
for when i went on a fast once but and i
didn't come from a poor family I can't
say that I came from a rich family but I
came from a fairly affluent family so I
would be the last person that would be
kind of the advocate for the hungry but
it's almost as if God dropped it in my
lap it was one of those things that I
could do in front of me and it was one
of those things that I was in charge of
I became chairman of the Select
Committee on hunger and it was my
responsibility and it was like there was
a way I could bring God into my
workplace so it was there it really
touched me I had a passion for it and I
had to learn about it because I didn't
know anything about it but
I can't solve the problem of the
environment and I didn't spend that much
time on the environment although my
environmental record was very good I
mean in Congress probably a hundred
percent but I was an environmental
legislature I worked on hunger and those
people that focused in the Congress to
me were always the ones that really got
something done so I focused and it
dropped in my lap and it was almost like
it was a god-given thing and but what
I'm saying is I'm the least of the
people that should be doing it because I
was never hungry I mean I was never poor